okay so this is the hard easy hey our
voices aren't adding up well that's
because we actually recorded this before
but like a dumbass I didn't have the mic
setup so Jason had the idea that we just
record the audio cuz that'll be easier
and faster yeah and and that we just put
it over this video yeah some things I
mean I think a little bit more like sync
up pretty good yeah that's my guess I
mean there's a part me that goes maybe
we should just record ourselves talking
as well with the video because you know
it's the exact same amount of work and
the camera doesn't have to do anything
different but I'm sure it's more work
somehow so we're just gonna do it this
way but actually if there is another
reason we're doing this because in the V
log that we just did and I didn't record
the sound too we talked about this
interesting idea that or just something
interesting we were saying in this
episode that I'm wondering if the
writers ever actually say no to anything
it seems like this is an environment
where absolutely anything is possible
and if they're just like let's try it
they never say no they're like okay
let's just go with it let's just do it
and in this episode we hit the heart
easy this is Jake and Finn come across a
crowd of goldfish cracker people and
it's one single goldfish cracker person
memory pop something says I was gonna
say hi but I was nervous well okay but
you then he buys him two other goldfish
cracker people fine so it works
oh and pretty much they say this is
giant frog who's tormenting them and
they're led by Jonathan cats which is
awesome because I love Jonathan cats
actually the original v-log I confess my
undying love to him for like 10 freakin
minutes yeah what cuz he's really cool
he's like this century's Bob Newhart
even though we currently have our Bob
Newhart but he's like Bob Newhart number
two sometimes like on the level of like
Matthew Broderick he is far better don't
laugh at anything Matthew Broderick
related shame on you I won't go on that
but I will call him Bob to heart because
he is like a sec
you're really gonna get up they can't
see you getting up it's only the audio
God you know it's great I don't care
it's Imagi IV log where he gets up and
walks away like a little that's
what he does um so anyway we got this or
he was just giving a mountain dude no
I'm still gonna claim you're getting up
and walk away like a so so we have
we have this episode this is that's
proof a girl's opening about and do love
to please sponsor me and drink your
product non-stop damn it
this is true control podcast but but
again it's we wanted to do this because
we actually did just love the idea that
we were talking about that you just
never say no to anything and this
episode ends with then trying to find
this frog creature and giant frog this
giant frog and Finn kisses him and he
turns into a prince
voiced by Bill Murray's father who has
got to be like in his 90s or something
and it's a pretty old guy and yet he
plays this young prince and they just
sort of a I remember how it even NZ just
sir and he's still Bill Murray's dad oh
and yet somehow hidden Bill Murray look
about the same age so yeah it's just
Bill Murray does not look good nowadays
but I digress
so yeah it's it was a fun episode it was
um it wasn't great it still had some
decent laughs there's still lots of my
love Jake trying to get the fire going I
love thinking struck by lightning and
that he's just suddenly fine I like I
said Jonathan Kent cracks me up anytime
he speaks my guess is that was probably
improvised but he's doing the oh no
where's my daughter
I'm over here hey we sounded like Joey
yes that could get confusing and I bet
you anything else in provides good you
there laughing and he usually lasts when
he provides us so because that's the way
he is he's just his that mean he's
terrible at it uh cuz it depends what
castile you're doing cuz like it fits in
the show there that he would kind of
laugh like hey that they do sound alike
my voice sounds alike like he gets into
his own bit so I mean oh it works for me
but yeah I mean it was
but what it certainly might me of the
last episode with the fire people
because it had a few good lasts but it
also seems a little draw it out and no
punt I know it's animated but I think
there's something to you know what it is
it's because of the rain I said in the
last one - there is something good yeah
there is something about the rain I just
don't like I I think it slows things
down I think it's boring to look at it's
gray it's drab it's not fun the only
time I've ever seen rain awesome is when
Frank Miller does it because his rain is
spaced out and cool and wind could be
blowing in the air for their clothes
then they get strike these awesome poses
and I don't know Frank Miller figured
out how to make rain look cool but
nobody else has so hanging in the rain
seeing in the rain but there was no
actual rain in that sequence does it
matter
our - rain did really look cool and I
brought up that the changing sequence
reminded me very much of Sailor Moon
yeah with the the boots wrapping around
and then stuff like that and Oh bro
you're fired
yeah that's right yeah my only real
complaint is that why did Finn not
remember how to make fire a few episodes
ago when uh Jake had his croak dream
Finn doubts I just feel if you there's
fire yes I'm rubbing my hands Killian
and then blowing yes what but if it's
just the audio they're not supposed to
know this it's not a radio drama but no
it's if you're acting out what he was
doing I was making a sound effect then
there's what yours you could be rubbing
your butt cheeks for all we know wait
let's see how that sounds
Sam sounds pretty similar I'm kind of
know they're smart enough they will get
it okay so I said okay this is somebody
selling weed about the cotton dude he
created fire from out of nowhere before
and this time around he just kind of was
like I don't know how to make fire it
was hilarious but it didn't seem to fall
for me in a show that has such good
continuity it didn't follow
yeah well that's somewhere timeout - is
that this shows continuity is
surprisingly
pretty tight um that there's a lot of
stuff that they'll go back to we were
mentioning that one with where they're
fighting the farm and he says you know
I'm gonna get the juice from the Cyclops
to bring you back to life after I break
every bone in your body so they really
do keep a you know a very tight tight
hold on their pants yes the pants of
continuity and pretty much they're
usually pretty good at it I think
something like this doesn't bother me
because a it's for a joke
and if the jokes pretty funny which I
thought pretty much was I love it laying
the stick down it just riding fire yeah
you know I think works okay but uh and
the other thing is I'm sure they forgot
I'm sure it wasn't intentional but we
started playing around this idea that
there's always gonna be a forum for
anything any kind of show they exist
where people go and they point out the
mistakes of a show this show seems so
good at referencing stuff that my guess
is fans had a problem with their people
were talking about or something that
they go back and they fix it you know
how I was even saying like you know man
does anyone ever change their clothes
and they start changing up their clothes
a little bit and the way they look
Knutson ward is in your closet and he's
listening to everything you say that is
scary awesome
sorry going I should feed him no you
shouldn't
so yeah but we were talking about how
okay so you got almost continuity going
and all these things at least I know I
brought up while watching the veal ox
usually in the next season they address
it or they have fun with it or they they
bring it up again uh and we were saying
like even with this if somebody brought
that up wait didn't know how to make
fire well is the thing you said about
getting him ahead with the farm or
whatever
oh yeah well finding the farm when you
punched me Jake it scrambled my brains I
do brain yeah man therefore I couldn't
create fire for a little while but now I
can you just wrote this butt cheeks if
you can see so both sacks like have
numerous yeah stop giving away my
secrets I'm not about stir whatever the
banana
come out so it's one of those things
where it's like this is totally doable
where you could go and have bananas come
out of you know where you could go and
you could just make up something for an
excuse later and bring it totally out of
context nowhere because that's just kind
of a show it is and I think so much of
that is because they just they never say
no and they just go with anything and I
think that they create an environment
where that can work I mean I wouldn't
say that for every environments like oh
no never say no always say yes that's
that's gonna lead to your destruction at
some point
barbar but most of the time I think that
it can it can work in the juice Ryan
this show knows I use it right and I
know it's how to use an environment to
use it right but a big thing that we're
talking about that I still want to do is
you brought up or we brought up that you
know what do they ever say no - do they
ever say no to something and I want to
go through their damn garbage we were a
thing about going through the garbage
and finding all the scripts and concept
are and everything that there's just a
big X on the go no too weird
kind of weird or - normal yeah that's
the other thing we're saying is that
maybe just like the link stuff they say
no no - is stuff that's like really
normal it's like it's just a guy in a
suit it sounds like no make four of them
and put them in an iceberg and make them
zombies and then put him back in the
iceberg and it's like hey at least you
got the number right this time yeah last
time I said three I never remember
number four cuz he's a boring guy he's
for the board oh look here oh I got some
gifts yeah if you watch this video to
the end you'll see he gets out those
things in the 90s there were a little
snappy things but yeah oh I don't even
know what this syncs up so I might just
leave the audio going yeah yeah hello in
president IDEO I don't know I didn't
keep hearing you picked this one right
yeah I pick that one mate oh yeah was
definitely not as good as together one
yeah no and the other one I'm screaming
really long but it's you can't yeah
you'll see me screaming the other one
but professional yeah very professional
this was probably the dumbest thing
we've ever done we you came up with the
idea Oh
oh no this is awesome uh yeah okay okay
this is the dumbest idea you ever came
up with it's just a dumbest idea I came
up with I'm a genius is this it is
awesome
come on people on the you know comment
section completely agree with me
everyone is gonna love this it's gonna
be nothing but praise because we're
following the Adventure Time people's
footsteps by not saying no to anything
I'm sure we're doing it just as well as
they are so to all of the Internet as
well as humanity you're welcome hey
those things are from the 90s aren't
they yeah look at the bleed underneath
yeah